[Musique]
moment solennel à windsor
un cortège mené par le prince charles a
suivi le cercueil du duc d'edimbourg
jusqu'à la chapelle saint georges les
petits fils du défunt
william et harry marchais l'un derrière
l'autre à la fin du cortège
la reine suivait dans sa bentley et
royales une minute de silence a été
observée avant le début des obsèques
dans l'ensemble du royaume uni en raison
de la pandémie
seuls trente invités ont pu assister aux
funérailles
quand tu arrives en crèche centre la
cérémonie fut célébré sobrement
entremêlés de prière et de musique
une image marquante de ces funérailles
demeure celle de la reine elizabeth
seule la tête basse aujourd'hui elle dit
adieu à son partenaire indéfectible
il aura été à ses côtés pendant 73
[Musique]
une cérémonie s'est aussi tenue à ottawa
sans public
entre les chants et les prières les
hommages préenregistrés se sont succédé
le prince philippe a eu un impact
positif sur nos communautés
d'un océan alors le prince philip duc
d'edimbourg et taco toi terre-à-terre
loyal et enthousiaste dans tous les
aspects de sa vie au cours de la
cérémonie les liens forts entre le
prince philip et le canada ont aussi été
soulignée il aura visité le pays près de
70 fois sa simplicité et sa facilité à
aborder les gens ont aussi été salués
il aura dédié sa vie au service des
autres estime à isabel rochât radio
canada montréal
[Musique]